..
In the very first immune video, where we talked about
The defense mechanisms are not specific, and we said if we had
Type some pathogen - let's say it's bacteria -
That our macrophages recognize either the proteins in the
Bacteria, or it may have been some other species of pathogenic organisms -
Some other sign of pathogens.
He does not know what kind of pathogen it is, but that's in
Enough enough.
You will swallow the causes of the disease.
So let's say this is a blimp.
One of those receptors affects one of the proteins
This is on the surface of this bacteria in this case
Say, Gee, this is not a good thing to be around and so on
You will swallow it.
So the membrane is just going to surround the nurse-and
This part will go.
Is going to kind of poke in and the nurse is going to
Get trapped and get soaked -
Phagocytosis.
So the final product - we've seen this in the first video where
I talked about the phobia - it's that we'll put a top-up
Then the membrane will be completely around.
This is going to poke in and bubble about this thing and
So we're going to be sitting nurse
Inside the pancreas.
They will be surrounded by a membrane.
That called membrane is ingested.
We learned that there are different types of
The macrophages - can be plump, can be
Neutrophils, can be dendritic cell - and we have
Like this and then we also saw in this video, it is not
Just do it - no buds
Just digest this thing.
This in itself is very useful.
They got these bacteria out of the way.
If this virus, it only got this virus out of the way.
But that is not even more.
It then takes it IT - or it breaks.
They do not actually have use - well, it breaks.
There are many ways you can do it, but the bottom line is, it
Operations on it.
..
They will disperse the nurse - and we saw this first video on
The macrophages that we actually have to wait for her bond solutions
Dump all types of particles that are going to break up and
These bacteria, in this case, are cut into
Its constituent molecules.
..
And then some sub-residue of food, special chains
Of peptides - remember, proteins are long
Chains of amino acids.
Proteins are short chains.
So you can take short chains of those and they are going to
Bond for special proteins.
..
This is mainly the theme of this video.
So let's say they bond to this protein, your bond
Your protein.
And then get those proteins transferred or get
Membrane or on the outer surface of the cell are this
Themselves along with the piece of pathogenesis.
That pathogen is the final product after fagocetozide
That the pancake will look something like this and that
These antigen will be presenting proteins, I think
We could call them and was bound to parts of it
The original nurse.
Let me do it here.
So it was a bit of the original cause of the disease that I had
It is painted in green here.
These proteins are right here, these are called - they
A fancy word, I talked about it in the previous video -
These complexes are called major histocompatibility,
Or MHC for a short time.
When we talk about macrophages or macrophages
Dendritic cells are present on special cases
Macrophages, major histocompatibility complexes
That what they offer after I have digested this
Molecule - this is the second MHC class.
Let me write this down.
This MHC class II protein.
It may sound like I'm really going to go into details
What these proteins are, but we're going to see this key
To activate other parts of the immune system, in particular
Cell mediated parts of the immune system.
So this was the case with balsam or thymus.
They swallow something, they chew all the top, and then portions
From something chewed until they were eating, hang it on these
The second MHC proteins and MHC proteins go to these
Cell surface.
The same thing - or actually not quite the same -
Something very similar happens with B cells.
So if we have a B cell - which color is good.
(B) for blue.
We know B stands for a stock exchange, but it can stand for bones
Marrow just as well.
Suppose that we have a B cell and they got a membrane by binding it
Body it.
Remember, very specific because B cells.
So all of the membrane binding antibodies, every 10,000 or so
Of them on this cell B, they also expressed the same
Variable part.
So this cell in particular.
So remember, this was unspecified.
When we talked about pimples, these guys only
I say, you're a bacterium.
I was a virus.
I do not know what type you are.
I'm just going to devour you.
You look Shady.
I'm going to mess you up.
I do not know what type you are or whether it is
You've seen before.
When we talk about B cells, we are talking about
Adaptive or immune-specific.
Even these - variable ends of these membranes are binding
Antibodies: Specific to certain parts of some
Pathogens, to some epitopes.
Remember, the abitobes were the parts of some pathogens
That these specific strings can be identified as bonds.
So let's say we are dealing with
Virus in this case.
Let's say that the virus just happens to be
Bond to this cell b.
Remember, there may be other - in fact, there
Definitely tons of other B cells around, but what
The changing parts are all different.
This is what I always find amazing about B cells that
They come from the same genetic line, and their genes
They were switched around in their development so that they could
They produce billions of combinations of these
Proteins, or variable ends of those antibodies.
So let's say we have some viruses.
Let me say it is bacteria.
When I did the other cell example, I said we were dealing
With viruses.
But let's say some new bacteria are just some part of
Its surface occurs only to bind only this cell B-
Because this cell is just right to combine.
So some part of its surface binds only to that cell b
There is a right.
That part of the surface that connects, remember, though
Called Beaverton.
This is the part of our connecting nurse
Variable Sequence.
This Bao cell will not bind this cell because it is
Different sequences here, but that binds to this B cell
And then start the activation process.
We will go to // - this in itself will sometimes get the cell b
Activated, but you can usually need help from a T helper
Cells - we will talk more about it.
We said, once this happens, you get it once
Activate or start the activation process, this guy
It gets soaked in fact - and I'm not talking about it at
Another video just because I did not want to go too
Lots of details.
Where it gets swept all this in cell B.
And then when it gets activated, it's rife
The same usually need T cells there and some
Become part of them plasma cells B, some part of them
Memory cells become b.
..
Remember, plasma cells b say, Jie, I've been activated.
I only produce tons of these antibodies.
So cell plasma will only produce tons of these
Antibody and spit on them so that they never start
Attach to more and more of the causes of the disease and just mess
Them in different ways, either mark them to the other
Macrophages or macrophages corrode them up - or mark two of them
So you can pack them where it can not work properly.
whatever.
I will not go into details in this.
This is when it gets activated.
But the interesting thing is that cell B will also be done
What do macrophages do?
The cell will take this guy in the cell.
Perhaps he was initially attached to a body - and broke
For him, take a piece of this nurse and attach to the MHC
II proteins are then displayed on the surface.
Even a cell is also present in antigen.
..
So this is also the second MHC complex-key
complex histocompatibility - and just so you know, histo
Means tissue.
So this is related to whether something is compatible with
Tissue in the body and we will talk about it and
How do you relate to planting and all that.
So this is also the second MHC class.
Either way, whether we're talking about B cells that
Identify a very specific nurse - it can be
Specific virus, specific protein, a specific bacteria,
Or in cases of macrophages, they will only say,
Oh, you look shady.
Let me be you.
I do not know what kind of bacteria or viruses or protein
You, but in both cases, they both submerge them, take
Cut them, chop them, and present them in these
The surface in the complex with the main
The complexes are histocompatibility.
Cells that do this are called even a professional antigen
Display cells.
..
This is what they do to live, although they do other
Things, as we saw.
The macrophages eat things.
B cells generate antibodies or memories where
They can be activated later to generate antibodies, but these
A professional antigen is called cell display.
An antigen in question is this small piece of
The actual thing that you are trying to follow, that little
Piece - the actual part of the pathogenesis, that's what
Antigen - where it is displayed to the antigen.
It is professional because it takes pathogens from
Fluids from our system and then sweeps them, breaks them,
And then submit them.
Now there is also a nonprofessional antigen
Display cells.
In fact, most cells have this.
In fact, even these guys.
In fact, I'm going to wait for the next video.
I realize all of my videos are getting long.
So you probably think, these guys in both cases
Submerge them, cut them, and offer them,
What's good for?
You'll see this second MHC, and these are recognized
Helper T cells.
It will be part of the mystery of how we have immunity
The system works.
So in the next video clip, we'll talk about the MHC I'm viewing
Cells, and all the cells of the body.
..